what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight update video before we get started
I actually want to clarify something
about the last video I uploaded about
Melisandre I'm not exactly sure what
happened to this video when I uploaded
it everyone seemed to watch it and enjoy
it for the first eight to ten hours I
would say but at some point that night
for whatever reason the video just
seemed to stop working correctly the
video about Melisandre was actually 14
minutes long but for some reason
whenever some of you tried to watch it
on a mobile device it would only play
the first 16 seconds of the video and
I'm still trying to figure out why this
happened that video still plays fine
whenever you watch it on a web browser
like Google Chrome but for some reason
it still only wants to play 16 seconds
worth whenever you try to watch it on
the YouTube app so for any of you that
still want to watch the Melisandre video
you can watch it on your computer if you
use Google Chrome or you can watch it on
your phone using your web browser I did
email YouTube about the glitch but they
have yet to respond to me so I apologize
to those of you that had trouble
watching it but I am hoping it doesn't
ever happen again
I just wanted to let some of you know
that the Melisandre video is actually 14
minutes long because I know some of you
commented and asked me why it was only
16 seconds long so hopefully it was just
a one-time glitch but now let's discuss
some of the more recent news regarding
the production of Game of Thrones Season
8 the Game of Thrones production crews
should be gearing up to film the a
season a game of Thrones within the next
few weeks they are scheduled to start
filming in October and once filming
starts we will start to get a bunch of
news and photos from the sets which
should give us all a good idea of what's
going to happen in the final season but
as we wait for some more info and photos
to come out I do have some other new
photos from one of the Game of Thrones
sets and I have another photo I want to
show you that was taken outside of their
main headquarters in Belfast Ireland the
first thing I want to discuss is
courtesy of Watchers on the wall who
provided this photo that was taken
outside of Titanic studios in Belfast
Ireland which is basically the main
headquarters for Game of Thrones
pre-production has already started and
they have already begun building some of
the sets and stages as they prepare to
film in October if you look closely at
this photo you can see that there is a
Dothraki Hut sitting right outside of
the studio
and according to the report there was
more than just one Hut there at this
studio apparently there was at least
three huts and two of them were the same
size and one of them was a much larger
Hut which could presumably be daenerys
targaryen we know that John and Daenerys
were heading north when they set sail
from Dragonstone and there were gonna
stop at white Harbor then traveled by
land up to Winterfell war they will most
likely set up camp as they prepare to
fight the night king and his army of the
Dead the night king and his army are
already south of the wall making their
way south but we will probably see John
and Daenerys get to Winterfell before
the night King gets there John and
Daenerys will need to get the Winterfell
as soon as possible and John's gonna
need to call all of his banners he has
in order to prepare themselves for this
great war and even though John and
Daenerys are in love I don't think John
is gonna have Daenerys sleeping in his
bed in Winterfell just yet so Daenerys
will most likely set up camp with her
council and all of her troops right
outside of the Winterfell walls I think
John is definitely in love with Daenerys
but he's gonna need to make sure all of
his supporters in the north are cool
with having Daenerys around before he
just comes out and says hey we just had
a big boat sex now you have to deal with
it I have a feeling John and Daenerys
are gonna hide their relationship for at
least a first episode or two before
they're open about it with everybody
else when John and Daenerys arrived
there's probably gonna be some
pissed-off northerners speaking out
because John brought a Targaryen into
their country but I think things will
get smoothed over pretty quickly when
they realize they're gonna need the
Narus in her dragons help in order to
survive they will need to realize they
cannot defeat the night King without her
dragons and her men there is a chance we
could see some of John's supporters
actually walk out on him when he
announces he basically bent the knee to
Daenerys but I think overall most of
them will end up accepting her simply
because she has already sacrificed one
of her dragons to save their king in the
north and she is there in person with
all of her troops ready to defend the
north and the realm with John so I think
Danny's actions are going to speak for
themselves and we might even get a
marriage alliance between John and
Daenerys at some point too but this all
depends on how fast the night king
actually gets south and this all depends
on what John and Daenerys decide to do
first they could sit around and prepare
winter fells defenses themselves or they
could bring the attack to the night King
and go after him before he actually gets
to Winterfell
but the timelines are too confusing for
me to give an accurate guess about what
they're gonna do first but now that the
photos are slowly starting to come out
we will learn more and more as the days
pass and the more photos that come out
the easier it will be for all of us to
put this final puzzle together and
figure out how all of this will play out
in the end it should be a lot of fun I
also have an update on the set at
Riverrun - about a week ago I made a
video regarding one of the sets that may
possibly be used again during season 8
Irish Thrones posted on Twitter that
Riverrun set was still operational and
very busy which led me to speculate that
we might actually see ed mere Tully once
again
or at least whatever army is left in
that area in the season seven finale
Jaime Lannister left Cersei and he is
now heading north and I can only assume
he will be going to Winterfell but I had
a feeling Jaime may try and make a pit
stop somewhere along his way he might
stop somewhere and try and get some
support and take however many soldiers
he can north with him we still have no
idea what is going on with Ed Muir
Tolley the last time anyone said his
name was in the season 6 finale when
Walder Frey told Jaime he put ed Muir
back in the cells after ed Muir helped
him gain access into the castle at
Riverrun welcome home my lord
come on all the forces within the castle
to lay down their arms open the gates
My Lord your Lord has given a command
this came together rather well your
father would be pleased sure he would be
had me rose back in the south can't go
killing my son by law wouldn't be right
did the family a bad name for all we
know ed Mira's still locked up in the
cells
I was hoping Oriya would set him free
when she wiped out House Frey but they
never did show us that but since Jaime
last spoke to him I was thinking Jaime
may try and get him to go north with him
considering ed Muir is technically
related to Arya and Sansa the Starks
will also be sending out Ravens warning
everyone that the night King is through
the wall in making his way south they
need to send out Ravens in hopes of
getting the support of anyone else
willing to come and help but Riverrun
became a dead plot we really have no
idea who is there or in charge
the phrase and Lannisters took it back
from the blackfish but Arya killed all
of the important phrase so I can't say
who is in control of Riverrun right now
I don't even know if we're ever gonna
see Ed Muir again it's too hard to say
what the only a handful of episodes left
but if someone is there Jaime may
possibly be able to get them to come
with him but I do have an update on this
set and as of right now it looks pretty
dead Irish Thrones said it was
operational and very busy but someone
who watches my videos reached out to me
and told me they would send me some
actual photos of the Riverrun set I have
to give a big shout-out to my friend zip
who sent me these photos via Twitter he
actually lives in the UK and he was
willing to drive to the set himself and
give me a real-time update as you can
see in the new photos I have this set
does look pretty dead he said there was
little to no activity on this location
when he was there he actually stopped by
two different times in the last week and
sent me the photos both times and it
seems to be on standby for right now he
did say there were a few security guards
there on location watching over the
property in the security guards
there both times he stopped by to take
the photos which could be good news
filming doesn't start until October so
we might not see much activity here just
yet if they do plan on using this set
again they have to be paying those
guards to watch over the place and they
haven't tore it down yet so they might
be planning on using it still he told me
he was going to go back in October when
filming starts and take some more
pictures from me and let me know if
there is any recent activity there so as
soon as I know more details I will let
you know too I have two things it for
taking the time out of his day to go
over there and take these photos at
least for now we can confirm the
Riverrun location seems to be dead with
no actual preparations taking place I
actually wouldn't be surprised if we
never see admir Tully again things seem
to be wrapping up so quickly they may
not make time for him in the remaining
story but hopefully within the next few
weeks the set becomes active because I
would like to see Jamie run into Ed
mirror again and show up in Winterfell
with at least a small army because we
all know they're gonna need every
swinging dick in the field fighting
against the night king and his army of
the dead but I guess I will end this
video right here I think I've blabble
enough and this one but I just wanted to
keep you all up-to-date and in the loop
with everything going on thus far I will
continue to keep you up-to-date with any
and everything Game of Thrones related
so make sure you hit that subscribe
button that way you can see all the new
videos each time they are released I
want to thank you all for watching
today's video I appreciate your
continued support as we head into this
long night during the off-season I also
want to thank all of you that support
the channel on patreon that really does
mean a lot to me so I hope you all have
a great day I will see you down in the
comment section bye